[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me put in any basically this you
which was gone
there's
[Music]
[Music]
we will Justin Trudeau Prime Minister of
Canada and our guest of honor allow that
uses a bonanza Monsieur is that it I can
you know that state communities Goods
Canada the taste it on our model is a
[Applause]
welcome everyone
if new Atos killed please inform what
exact a year as at City money from the
Puget Sound to Anaheim
I knew Malala was a smart girl from
reading her book but I now realize just
how wise she is she chose the right day
to come back to Canada to receive her
honorary citizenship on the day the NHL
playoff start already should true
Canadian citizen Econet down at the pier
oh mama
vishwas scale it by five New Jersey I
think a city like wood siding camasta
swath exactly kick an agenda a Navajo
lava at Schwalm is ucomfy on scale
forgiveness in my name a lot of asian
fine-pointed kid we have a big program
ahead so let's get it started
chief commit nano don't have a medieval
sign minutes for the uniqueness of the
game she is extremely qualified please
welcome the Minister of Immigration
refugees and citizenship your honorable
on the team who stay
it's a great privilege for me to be part
of this tribute to Canada's newest
honorary citizen and a most remarkable
and inspiring young woman Malala
yousufzai say for more and grant
privileged a participate a la ceremonie
de zone our grand rahman allah took
their near said why an honor led to
Canada on Jean Pham who flew when Makabe
a s parent General made Malala yousufzai
every so often Canada bestows honorary
citizenship when an extraordinary person
who reflects the very best of our ideals
of freedom Human Rights respect and
tolerance and stands as an inspiring
example to the world while being an
honorary Canadian does not confer legal
status under the Citizenship Act it
connects us in spirit and recognizes a
contribution to the advancement of
humanity that has touched the hearts of
Canadians honorary citizenship is
conferred upon a recipient by joint
resolution of the houses in Parliament
it has only happened five times industry
Malala yousufzai is part of an
internationally distinguished and
remarkable group of individuals that
includes people like the other hard on
Sun Tzu Chi the Dalai Lama Nelson
Mandela around Wallenberg Malala urine a
extraordinary young person was captured
the respect and admiration of Canadians
everywhere you've become an important
figure in the critical international
struggle for the rights of girls to
education and against the suppression of
the rights of youth Canadians are
delighted that you've accepted the honor
of not only becoming our 6th ever
honorary Canadian citizen but also the
youngest ever on
citizen of this country so without
further ado I'd like to invite the right
honourable Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
to present the certificate to our
distinguished honorary Canadian thank
you very much
I would now like to invite the Honorable
Justin Trudeau to say a few words okay
just either not have the Heslin that
happens she states look I mean this
let's can adapt okay come mr. Pathak
thank you all for gathering here to mark
this historic occasion today we proudly
bestow honorary Canadian citizenship on
Malala yousufzai a young woman from
Pakistan who has done tremendous things
for the people of her country and for
the children of the world convulsive a
Malala the shrine Honua knocked up the
milquetoast miss a variety of you see a
fellow head revision here
Mamiya monomer commemorative Daguerre's
ec sora Caliente Paloma say don't only
know her pre-delay poor know the final
Malacca yay Ricardo de set ceremony
davide cironi Guillermo suppliant a
Canadian at sit on a week
Malala Malala decision Pearson salma
agha cigar set stereo BL so joyous after
de haut de Piedra
if you respect page mode Malala your
story is an inspiration to us all the
violence you survived at the hands of
the Taliban didn't deter you as it would
have for so many others rather you stood
even stronger in the face of oppression
your passion for justice only
intensified when you address the UN in
2013 you said we realize the importance
of light when we see darkness we realize
the importance of our voice when we are
silenced Malala yousufzai for bravely
lending your voice to so many we thank
you and from this day forward we are all
proud to call you
here's again
mother lived a pool that I told that
their Prime Minister Trudeau will now
present to Malala the Canadian peace
tower fight
Jennifer Shatila national Western and
Erdogan is the Tawaf
the singer national anthem here's the
Ottawa regional youth choir
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
Oh Jenna Jenna Jenna thought I was
attending she's given Amanda no podium
as the father of a one-year-old girl I
look forward to one day bragging to her
that I was once able to say the words
Malala it would be an honor for you to
come to the podium for key words
thank you so much for prime minister
trudeau people of canada for this
incredible honor I'm honored to be given
this honor of the honorary citizenship
of Canada and I accept it as proud
citizen of Pakistan and as a proud
question and it is not just honoring
citizenship of Canada but it is also
being Ganga's friend and I warmly
accepted and I want to thank Canada for
his passion for girls education force
passion for humanity for Refugees and
for standing up for women's rights and
for peace and I'm really excited to be
here to meet you all and you are a true
example to the world of what it means to
stand up for humanity and I'm hopeful
that you will inspire many more
countries and many more leaders to
follow your footsteps and I am hopeful
that together through a work we can
ensure that every girl can get quality
education that is my mission and I'm
sure that you all will join me in this
cause once again I'm really thankful and
and this is this is an honor and a great
opportunity to see Prime Minister
Trudeau because everyone was excited
especially all the people are singing
like the UK in the u.s. I'm gonna say
are you meeting Trudeau and I check it
so yeah I've done it vegetable it's
finally done so I want to say that
Trudeau is an amazing person and
inspiration and a person who is standing
up without any fear for feminism for
women's rights for equality and who's
standing up among a time and during the
time where the world is hopeless Prime
Minister is coming forward speaking out
for Refugees and women so he is a true
example and I'm sure that other world
leaders were learned from him thank you
[Music]
Joe Gatto to the Moravians want to
relieve squeaky Amaka he-man 11-week la
clé and I did get a gap Alomar time and
I'm showing yellow I feel like this
library might be missing one book Malala
would you do this building the honor of
presenting your book and this is so
Gallagher parliamentary librarian
[Applause]